dans la nuit de mercredi à jeudi 29 juin
alors que de nombreuses émeutes ont
éclaté dans toute la France après le
décès de Naël un adolescent de 17 ans
mortellement touché par le tir d'un
policier lors d'une intervention pour
refus d'obtempérer la prison de Fresnes
a été le théâtre de violentes attaques
orchestrée par une trentaine voire une
quarantaine d'individus sur les images
que le Figaro a pu consulter on peut
voir plusieurs individus vêtus de noir
cagoulés ou recouvert d'une capuche
s'attaquer au poste de police situé
devant la prison ces hommes ne se sont
pas introduits dans la prison mais ont
seulement pu pénétrer sur le domaine
pénitencier durant plusieurs minutes ils
se sont attaqués au poste de garde qui
se trouve à l'entrée d'établissement des
mortiers de cocktail Molotov bouteilles
pierre et de parpaings vers 4h du matin
des CRS ont finalement été déployés aux
abords du centre pénitentiaire aucune
tentative d'évasion n'a été recensée le
garde des sceaux Eric Dupont-Moretti
s'est rendu sur place ce jeudi 29 juin
vers 13h30 il a fustigé tous ceux qui de
façon irresponsable crachent sur la
police et la justice les désignant comme
des complices moraux des exactions
commis cette nuit